welcome back here are our categories for
the double jeopardy round we've got
ourselves does jeopardy ever try to
snipe long-running champions like James
Holt sour and shrug emoji interesting
selection should be a very exciting game
let's begin
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show where we
ask people to think long and hard about
the truth but you know what at least we
don't ask them to listen to that
anxiety-inducing jeopardy theme song but
did you think I would play it no one can
afford the royalties to that thing
anyway in our first ever jeopardy
episode we took a look at the math and
science behind the way that jeopardy
champion and professional gambler James
Holt's our ROK's scoring records and
pretty much broke the game itself if you
haven't seen that episode give it a
watch right yeah in the upper right hand
corner of the screen and bring your
grandma along grandmas are the
preeminent experts on Jeopardy and I
guarantee that she's not watching a
YouTube breakdown of her favorite game
show airing at 7 p.m. weekday nights as
an added bonus during the mid roll ads
of this video you can probably do some
family bonding over her old-school crush
on Alex Trebek y'all caught up good well
I was doing the research and crunching
the numbers on James it was pretty easy
to see why he dominated the competition
but all the reasons we talked about on
that last episode make it difficult to
figure out why he would have lost well
it turns out that a lot of people had
plenty of theories about what exactly
went wrong in James's last game James
who would usually wager massive amounts
of money in Final Jeopardy at a measly
$1,399 which seemed totally
uncharacteristic indicating to some that
he was intentionally trying to lose and
yeah initially this bet totally looked
fishy but unfortunately the theory
doesn't pan out because it's totally
justified when you look at it through
the lens of Statistics fire up the
calculation musicboys in a final
Jeopardy round there's one question
meaning that there are eight possible
outcomes to final jeopardy now we've
covered many times at this point that
James Gamble's for a living so he knows
all about the odds and as a professional
better he must make a bet that
guarantees that he'll win in as many of
those 8 outcomes as possible now Emma's
in the lead and she's shown herself to
be a big bettor from early in the a did
you you did what did you wager oh god
she even wrote her master's thesis using
an analysis of Jeopardy clues so James
knows that he's playing against someone
who knows the game as well as he does
based on the
facts James know she's gonna wager
everything or at least bet a lot
basically the only way James can beat
her is if she gets the question wrong
something that he doesn't really have a
whole lot of control over so based on
this he actually makes the best bet he
can by betting just a little bit just
enough to stay ahead of the third-place
player and hoping that Emma answers
wrong she doesn't and he loses but the
moral of the story is that James made
the best bet based on game theory and
statistics so that's the analysis of one
question out of an amazing run of 32
games but how did James wind up in
second place going into final jeopardy
to begin with is it possible that
jeopardy rigged the game against him and
if we're gonna ask that for me the first
question isn't did they or didn't they
but instead what jeopardy have a motive
to do anything like that I mean James
created more buzz for the show than
almost ever before in history
which the only rival being 10 Jennings's
amazing 70 plus episode run and that led
to Jeopardy crushing it in the ratings
even beating out shows like The
Bachelorette
similarly Google Trends indicates that
James's run drastically increased
interest in the show see these two peaks
on the graph of interest search for
Jeopardy both of those are James and
that big old dip in the middle is from
the teachers tournament that happened in
the middle of his run bigger ratings and
more interest in the show translate to
more money from advertisers both in
terms of commercials and in ingame
sponsorships and it might stand a reason
that James was winning a lot of cash to
be sure but that couldn't have made up
for all those ad dollars that would be
pouring in rights from all the increased
ratings well not so fast on that front
it turns out advertising space for
television is generally sold months
before specific episodes air that
shouldn't surprise even people who don't
watch traditional television YouTube ads
work in largely the same way which is
why it takes months for YouTube to
recover from ad epochal I so with ads
sold way in advance it's actually very
difficult for a show like Jeopardy to
capitalize on the publicity it gets from
an individual player because they can't
predict when the next big fan favorite
is gonna emerge or how long he or she is
gonna last secondly chose like who else
to be a millionaire and Deal or No Deal
that actually give away a million
dollars have a little secret they have
insurance prize indemnity insurance
covers companies that offer massive
jackpots for rare occurrences which
include things like
somebody making a perfect March Madness
bracket hitting a hole-in-one or winning
a million bucks on a game show
but like all insurance policies prize
indemnity insurance hinges on the idea
that the event being insured against is
rare jeopardy almost certainly doesn't
have an insurance policy like that
because it's prize giveaways are more
consistent but also a whole lot smaller
at least they were smaller until James
Holt's hour came around in season 34 of
Jeopardy average daily winnings of the
200 normal non tournament games was 19
thousand nine hundred and thirty nine
dollars in James Holt's hours thirty two
wins he averaged just under seventy
seven thousand almost four times as much
as the average daily winnings for 32
games straight now I don't know all the
specifics of Jeopardy's financials but
I've made shows on the internet for a
long time to know a couple of things
about productions and budgets and if
suddenly your budget has to account for
an extra two hundred and eighty-five
thousand dollars per week given away to
one single contestant that's gonna be a
huge problem for you that money is not
gonna just appear out of nowhere and no
amount of Gold Bond medicated powder
sponsorship is gonna make up for it so
on the question of whether jeopardy had
a motive to get James off the show the
answer here is a big yes so that leaves
us with the single biggest question of
all did Jeopardy try to sabotage James
Holt's hour and it's at this point that
I should mention that I've watched all
those episodes and for legal reasons I'm
telling you up front and I could only go
on what I can observe and the numbers I
can crunch as an outside observer and by
studying them like I'm doing the SAT
like the bar exam I don't want jeopardy
suddenly making up its losses on James
by suing the heck out of me so all that
being said if you were to ask me whether
the game changed over the course of
James's run to make it a less likely for
him to win or at the very least make it
less likely that he wins as large of
amounts as he was used to winning the
answer is yes now obviously jeopardy has
the right to change anything about the
game that they want to and if they were
trying to send a player home there are
three changes the show could make that
would help make that happen one changing
the types of questions they ask to
changing the placement of daily doubles
and three changing the difficulty of the
game
so let's look at all three of these
individually shall we a possibility one
changing the questions they asked now I
pored over the history of James's games
to look for patterns and questions that
he either missed or that none of the
players answered correctly which are
known in jeopardy fandom has triple
stumpers not a lot of patterns emerged
because James simply didn't miss
questions that often it appears he
wasn't quite as strong in wordplay
categories as he was with like the
trivia categories and Alex Trebek
alluded to James mentioning that he
didn't know much about ballet but the
composition of the categories didn't
appear to change significantly over time
besides this is the kind of setup that
would probably look pretty darn
conspicuous I mean if jeopardy wants to
set somebody up to lose it can't just
make eight ballet categories in the same
game and expect nobody to notice I'd say
it's pretty safe to say that the show
did not change what it was asking about
in response to James's dominance so then
what about possibility number two
changing the placement of the daily
doubles the daily doubles was one of
James's biggest weapons as we covered in
the previous episode because the crux of
his strategy was to accrue a decent
amount of cash and then bet most or all
of it on the daily doubles to get a big
lead but James also generally started at
the bottom of the board with the most
expensive questions to try and build up
that bankroll quickly so the show
presumably could have moved daily
doubles to a place that they knew James
was likely to go first so he basically
wouldn't have enough money to bet big on
them so did they do that in his first 10
games the one Daily Double in the
jeopardy round was in the bottom row
four times meaning those were the ones
James would hit early on preventing him
from betting big as his run went on
you'd expect more and more of those
daily bevels to be down there but in his
last 10 games it was only in the bottom
row twice looking at the math changing
this placement wouldn't always have
helped either if James picked all the
thousand-dollar Clues in a single
jeopardy he could still have as much as
$5,000 to wager on that Daily Double
if it was always placed in the bottom
The Daily Double placements in double
jeopardy also didn't change that much
over James's run so keeping away from
daily doubles wasn't really within the
show's control in which case it would
have made sense for the show to start
putting very hard questions in Daily
Double spots hoping to make James miss
and I think jeopardy tried this in
particular in game 27 of James
run now ranking the relative difficulty
of questions is an inexact science but I
did ask the whole theorist team these
two questions one about an obscure Bible
passage and the other one about a city
in Germany with a population the size of
Missoula Montana team theorists has some
pretty good trivia players and not only
did none of them know the answer none of
us had even heard of these sorts of
things so this probably screwed James up
right wrong he didn't select either of
those and the poor guy who did select
him missed both James wound up winning
that game by a margin of over $70,000
suffice it to say that even if jeopardy
was tinkering with the difficulty levels
of the daily doubles those weren't the
things that brought James down because
there was really no controlling who
would wind up with them and that leaves
us with possibility number three
changing the difficulty of the game once
again measuring the difficulty of a
Jeopardy game might seem a bit
subjective but there's actually a metric
that hardcore jeopardy fans use that can
help quarry at score is a fancy term
that's used as a standardizing metric
for the game it disregards wagering and
only considers the values of clues that
were answered correctly and incorrectly
therefore the more questions that the
players answer correctly without missing
the higher the combined quarry at score
and the easier the game is ranked just
remember higher quarry at score equals
easier game if the answer every single
question correctly and no player misses
a thing the combined quarry at score for
the game is counted at 54,000 so if
jeopardy was trying to sink James's
battleship by purposely making the
questions harder one would expect to see
a fairly drastic change in the quarry at
score relative to all the other scores
from games around it in fact it's a
strategy that the show has used before
with their last major contender Ken
Jennings yep it seems like jeopardy even
gave Ken the boot you see the average
combined quarry at scoring 10 Jennings
is 75 games was 39,000 to 13 but the
game that he lost had a score of only
29600 well below average for not just
his run of games but for the entire
season of games that had come before
even he arrived on the scene and Ken
Jennings has lost the game was very
messy with lots of wrong answers and
triples numbers and this
Gorn was close leading into the Final
Jeopardy round so when Ken missed the
final question and his opponents didn't
he was just done the concept here is
that by making the game super hard even
the best players are gonna be missing a
lot of questions and can't get any sort
of momentum so historically dominant
players are gonna no longer be able to
get the lead everyone is on a level
playing field because no one really
knows the answers which leaves everyone
in a close race leading into the endgame
so is this the strategy that jeopardy
use to finally house James Holt's hour
the answer is they clearly tried it in
general the combined quarry at score and
James's games was actually much higher
it was at forty five thousand 406 but
there were a couple of specific games
late in James's runs that were
significantly harder than the earlier
games two games in particular where it
seems like they really tried to oust him
head combined quarry at scores under
35,000 that is more than 10,000 points
less than average that is a huge margin
of difference you can even see on some
of the questions where James is just
like WTF was that question these were
messy messy games they were hard to
watch actually because the players were
just stumbling all over themselves with
wrong answers and missteps at least
every player was having a hard time but
James you see it turns out that in both
of these games in addition to them being
a bad audience experienced watch James
just absolutely destroyed his opponent's
winning by over $70,000 both times James
couldn't be taken out by a lower scoring
game like ten for one important reason
Ken miss Final Jeopardy with decent
regularity but James almost never did
Ken Jennings accuracy rate on Final
Jeopardy clues in his initial run was
69% nice but James had a whopping 97%
accuracy rate on Final Jeopardy so it
was unlikely that a hard low scoring
game would result in James missing a
question that another player got so not
even changing the difficulty of the game
threw him off or at least not even
making it hard there is one other way to
manipulate the difficulty of the game
and that's by making the questions
easier that's right it seems like
jeopardy may have done the exact
opposite of what they did Ken Jennings
if every player knows every single
answer puts everyone on a level playing
field it removes James's advantage of
trivia knowledge and reduces the game to
just buzzer reactions and smart betting
and that's exactly what happened in the
game that James lost the combined quarry
at score for the game that Austin James
was fifty three thousand two hundred it
is the highest combined Coria score in
jeopardy history in other words it is
the single easiest game on record for
the entire run of Jeopardy James was
clearly prepared for the absolute
hardest questions that jeopardy could
throw at him but he had no defense
against them making the game easier for
everyone else they threw at him the one
and only thing that could even the odds
back in the houses favor
so did jeopardy set James up to lose I
mean you can't exactly say that but you
can say that for both James's run and
Ken Jennings is wrong with a game that
got him both eliminated was a weird
statistical anomaly where the games were
either one of the hardest in Ken's case
or the absolute easiest in James's case
in jeopardy history and the one that got
James Houston was not only the easiest
game but was also the one where he went
up against a player who studied jeopardy
questions for her master's thesis and a
game that asked a final jeopardy
question about Shakespeare which is
wouldn't you know it what the players
undergraduate thesis was about like I
said you can't exactly say that jeopardy
is rigged for legal reasons I don't want
to get myself into any sort of real
jeopardy here but let me just call out
the facts and let you make the decision
for yourself but hey that's just a
theory a theory
[Music]
everyone can either get it right or
wrong
let's burn through the combination shall
we right right right right right wrong
right wrong right right wrong wrong
wrong right right wrong right wrong
wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong right
right that all eight